اعلنت كتائب القسام قصفها ب 20 صاروخا
سكنه ليمان في الجليل الغربي انطلاقا من
جنوب لبنان ردا على المجازر في غزه
واغتيال صالح العاروري ورفاقه في ضاحيه
بيروت الجنوبيه من جهته اعلن حزب الله
تنفيذه اربع هجمات على مواقع عسكريه
اسرائيليه قباله الحدود اللبنانيه وقال ان
مقاتليه استهدفوا بصواريخ بركان جنود
الاحتلال في محيط
رويسات العلم كما هجموا تجمعات للجنود في
تلشعر ومحيط موقعي الراهب والعباد من
ناحيتها شنت الطائرات الاسرائيليه غارات
على بلدات راشيا الفخاره وحوله وعيت الشعب
ومروحين وسهل القليله كما تعرض محيط بلدات
كفر شوبه والخيام وعيت ترون ومارون الراس
لقصف
مدفعي معنا من بلده رميش جنوب لبنان مدير
مكت الجزيره مازن ابراهيم ومعنا من الجليل
الاعلى مراسله الجزيره جفاره البديري اهلا
بكما وابدا معك مازن لتجمل لنا تطورات هذا
اليوم واللافت فيها هي استهداف كتائب
القسام ب 20 صاروخ الجليل الغربي طبعا هذا
بالاضافه الى الصواريخ التي اطلقها حزب
الله بالفعل وسيله من غير المبالغ به
القول ان هذه الجبهه تشهد حرب استنزاف
مفتوحه منذ الثامن من اكتوبر الماضي هذه
الحرب وحرب الاستنزاف تاخذ
طابعا متصاعدا وتحديدا خلال الفتره
الماضيه صحيح ان العمليات ترتفع حينا
وتتراجع احيانا اخرى ولكن هنالك نسق بتنا
نشهده نراقبه خلال الفتره الماضيه وهو
يؤشر الى ارتفاع وتيره العمليات العسكريه
من الجانبين اليوم
الصواريخ التي اطلقتها كتائب القسام من
لبنان باتجاه ثكنه ليمان على بعد ثلاثه
كيلومترات من الحدود اللبنانيه هي مؤشر
اضافي على ان هذه المواجهه تاخذ طابعا
متعددا سواء من خلال العمليات العسكريه
التي ينفذها حزب الله والتي نفذها اليوم
وهي خمس عمليات استهدفت من ضمن ما استهدفت
المواقع العسكريه من جهه وايضا مستوطنات
اسرائيليه نتحدث عن مستوطنه المناره وايضا
اطلاق صاروخين اجاه مستوطنه المطلي كذلك
الامر بالنسبه لهذه الصواريخ التي اطلقتها
كتائب القسام ردا على المجازر التي تحصل
في قطاع غزه وايضا عمليه اغتيال صالح
العاروري ورفاقه هي استهدفت بصواريخها
العشرين والتي اطلقت باتجاه الجليل الغربي
هي استهدفت هذه القاعده العسكريه
الاسرائيليه والتي تاتي ضمن استهدافات
متعدده الان الطائرات الاسرائيليه تكاد لا
تغادر الاجواء هنالك عمليات اطبا باقيه
تنفذها هذه الطائرات من خلال غارات نرصدها
بشكل يومي باتت وتيرتها متسارعه متزايده
تستهدف مناطق حساسه تعتبر من ضمن القواعد
الرئيسيه لحزب الله سواء في وادي الوقي او
غيره من المناطق التي تصب هذه المقاطعات
الحربيه صواريخها باتجاهه وبالتالي ما
يمكن قوله وسيله بان ديناميه هذه الجبهه
باد باتت متغيره هنالك ايقاع جديد
وبالتالي الحديث المتزايد خلال الفتره
الماضيه عن احتماليه الحرب عند الجبهه
الجنوبيه للبنان وبمعزل عن اتخاذ قرار من
هذا الطرف او ذاك ولكن من الواضح ان هذه
الديناميه قد تؤدي الى تدحرج الامور لاننا
خلال الفتره الماضيه نتحدث عن الاسبوعين
الاخيرين منذ اللحظه التي قامت بها
اسرائيل باغتيال صالح العاروري وما اعقب
ذلك من خلال الصواريخ التي اطلقها حزب
الله اولا باتجاه قاعده ميرون على بعد
سبعه كيلومترات في العمق الاسرائيلي اعقب
ذلك استهداف قاعده دادو العسكريه وهي
القاعده المخصصه لقياده المنطقه الشماليه
باسرها على بعد 12 م من الحدود اللبنانيه
وايضا صواريخ القسام التي تطلق بهذا
الاتجاه كل هذه الامور تدلل بالاضافه الى
الغارات الاسرائيليه الشديده والتي ب
نرصدها بالعشرات يوميا وفي مناطق متعدده
وهنالك تتحدث عن المقاتلات الحربيه وليس
المسيرات كل هذه المعطيات ا اذا ما عطفت
على التصريحات بعجاله السياسيه والصادره
من لبنان والعسكريه والتهديدات من اسرائيل
قد تشي بان الايام المقبله قد تحمل مفاجات
كثيره ابقى معنا مازن انوه فقط الى هذا
الخبر العاجل مصدر ملاحي يمني للجزيره
يقول قوات انصار الحوثيين استهدفت سفينه
في البحر الاحمر اتحول اليك جفاره بديري
جفارا مثل ما قال مازن ايقاع جديد على
الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان الجبهه الشماليه
لاسرائيل ورئيس هيئه الاركان قال كما
نقلنا قبل قليل في خبر عاجل احتمال نشوب
حرب عند الحدود مع لبنان خلال الاشهر
القادمه اعلى بكثير من السابق كيف يمكن
فهم دلاله هذا الكلام والتطورات الميدانيه
كذلك تصريحات هرسي هاليفي وهو رئيس هيئه
الاركان الاسرائيليه وخلال تفقده لم
مناوره عسكريه في منطقه الشمال اكد بان
احتمال نشوب الحرب مع لبنان اصبحت اقرب
خلال الاشهر القادمه واحتمالها اكبر عما
كان عليه في السابق واضاف ان الحرب على
غزه اعطت معطيات جديده للجيش الاسرائيلي
بكيفيه اداره هذه الحرب والنسق فيها وان
هناك الكثير من العبر التي استفاد منها
الجيش اليش الاسرائيلي خلال الحرب على غزه
واضاف بان الجيش يتمتع حسب وصفه بالثقه
الذاتيه العاليه والقدرات الكبيره ولكن هو
في النهايه قال جمله واحده ان الجيش لازال
بحاجه الى مزيد من التدريبات هذا معناه ان
الاقتراب نحو الحرب اصبح واضحا وكبيرا
ويتصاعد حتى وان كانت تصريحات هليفي وهي
من اعلى الان هيئه عسكريه اسرائيليه فان
الامور بالفعل على الصعيد الميداني تتصاعد
اكثر فاكثر وهذه التصريحات وكانها اما وفق
مراقبي تلويح جدي بان الحرب قادمه لا
محاله على لبنان بعد الانتهاء من الحرب
على غزه ولكن في ذات الوقت هاليفي يؤكد
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي على الارض ميدانيا
ليس جاهزا بكامل الخبرات التي يملكها لانه
يتحدث حث ايضا عن الروح القتاليه لدى
الافراد اذا هناك مجمل تصريحات يدلي بها
هاليفي خلال هذا اليوم في ظل تصاعد
العمليات العسكريه وتبادل اطلاق النار على
جبهتي الشريط الحدودي فالجيش الاسرائيلي
خلال الساعه الماضيه قال بانه خلال دقائق
تم استهداف الخليه التي قامت باطلاق اكثر
من 20 صاروخا اتجاه منطقه راس الناقوره اي
بمعنى ان الجيش يريد ان يقول ان الساحه
على طول خط الجنوب اللبنانيه مفتوحه امامه
ويستطيع ان يتحرك بسهوله وان العمليات
خلال هذا اليوم كانت بقصف مدفعي ومن خلال
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه على كثير من
المواقع ولكن في المقابل كان هناك ايضا
اطلاق قذائف صاروخيه على الاقل صاروخ مضاد
للدروع اتجاه منطقه المطله
وايضا دوت صافرات الانذار على الاقل في
اكثر من 20 موقعا على طول الشريط الحدودي
وشيء اخير فقط ننوه له وسيله ان الطائرات
سواء المسيره او الحربيه الاسرائيليه لم
تغادر الاجواء طوال الساعات القليله
الماضيه هذا لم نكن نلحظه خلال الفتره
الماضيه بان يستمر ويتواصل
لطا بشكل منخف خلال هذا الوقت من الزمن
اشكرك جزيل الشكر جبار البديري مراسلتنا
من الجليل الاعلى كما اشكر كذلك مازن
ابراهيم مدير مكتب الجزيره من بلده رميش
جنوب لبنان